hey guys came here with no GS news
update for you do you like street fights
beaches and also returning characters
with questionable hair well then this
news video is probably for you Capcom
has announced plans for an online beta
of Street Fighter 5 as well as giving a
glimpse of returning character Charlie
Nash details on the beta are extremely
light but Capcom says it intends for it
to be the largest and most ambitious
online beta program in franchise history
the beta will take place on playstation
4 and PC and it will be essential to
collect your feedback and to ensure the
street fighter 5 is the best iteration
yet North American gamers can guarantee
themselves access by pre-ordering no
dates for the beat or intense Nordic app
called indicate how long the b2 would
run for how much content will be
included whether cross-platform play
will be tested or any of the other
questions you're no doubt wondering more
details will be announced some time
though in the future according to a cap
community blog post more concrete
information was offered though on a
returning character Capcom had
previously announced Charlie Nash Nash
is supporting a new look featuring his
trademark glasses and weird lightning
unicorn hair we're still awaiting an
ultimate release date for street fighter
5 however which was only nights back in
December as a ps4 and PC exclusive so
how do you feel about the prospect of a
street fighter 5 beta you think it
really helped them nail the balancing
this time am I excited to fight
injustice once more as Charlie's let me
know in the comments down below and for
all the rest of the news you could
possibly need about Street Fighter 5
just come on back to gamespot